urubus ao bem vindo a mais um vídeo e
hoje vou tentar fazer é me libertar aqui
é pra você gostar de novela porque muito
quem é mesmo a china que eu já fiz até
agora
mas não se enganem é que para mais
ganhos ao os testes que eu fiz porque
você tem que ter um relatório porque em
casa para ser transparente e volta para
trás para mais 15 metros a incrível
isto deve se ao facto de o ter posto em
que duas bolas daquelas do cabelo
parceiras são feitas de metal
extremamente elástico
a posição inicial
o tutorial uma cozinha segura foi chefe
da sac da mola cabelos quanto você vai
estar melhor setorial que consiga lançar
em qualquer área não só não cai
eu posso chegar aqui com o dedo não
posso simplesmente aqui em prática um
dia por baixo o hit para uma coisa muito
importante que é a primeira ação do
projeto setorial fizerem este brinquedo
aqui é porque tem mesmo muita força br
então vamos ver isso agora o teste foi
apoio tutorial passo a passo alguns lá
bem só para vocês fazerem vista que
acabaram de ver precisar desde a volta
de 45 patins de picolé deste ou seja que
os potentes lado você encontrar em à
venda para com como simples latina em
que duas bolas para o cabelo que quando
já usei que comprar mais só que eu
encontrei estas duas outras não tinham
esse book que estão vendo aqui vocês
cumprir com este buraco pois na hora de
pôr um fio é mais fácil um clipe aqui
tem que ser com uma lâmina bem fininha
neste caso uma tesoura ou então para cá
vinha fazer jardinagem comentários podem
usar outra qualquer
é importante que ela seja bastante
resistente e mais importante é este aqui
vocês vão lá e fazer o que vocês vão
conseguir certeza fazer é muito fácil
mesmo
podem tentar cruzar umas luvas que não
usarem sempre olha que aconteceu é mais
rápida
como é que vocês vão fazer isso em casa
levo daqui
agora pressiona e vou neste traçado
deixe lá e fazem outra linha
hoje é salvar o tesouro que considerem
por cortar e já está mesmo na forma você
tem que fazer isso para todas as
pecinhas a cair aqui mais uma é essa
aqui é para o gatilho
votar é só contar com vocês conseguem
fazer é difícil aqui então vocês vêem
aqui tinha uma faca fazendo assim
proporciona tem que fazer até chegar
outro lado pode até fazer o corinthians
lá depois vir a fazer outro lado não
poderão nem quer
já dá pra ver aqui marca
já cheguei é preciso mais alta passa
aqui o morhan
pronto está já a quito cortar só vocês
vão fazer para todas as pessoas que
estão aqui está bem explícita que
mostrar na folha de ofício mas apps 2002
pessimistas que a china consiga atrasado
tem que fazer duas pessoas destas aqui
dois tanques estiverem lá até por
turistas e isso vocês vão guardar a cair
depois
você tem por duas viradas para o mesmo
lado fazer força de frente e cacau é
exata
vocês vão pôr com o design design ataque
com a parte tem pintado ou seja da
frente assim pois assim faz muito mais
tensão à veja aqui a parte exposta à
mente é enfeitada
fica assim vocês marcar em maio
britânica tanto frio e agora por cola
num dos lados e no outro lado
e agora esse [ __ ] tentar centralizar
agora porque cola aqui
e por outra péssima aqui e agora vou
deixar secar roupa da estréia que o
esquema dê certo enquanto isso vamos
fazer isso aqui a gente aqui uma a forma
já era uma dessas pessoas grandes e por
aqui depois vai ficar aqui é esta podem
verificar quando em cima por esta aqui
por cola
vocês vão deixar com que nos possibilite
em cima com seu canal por onde as coisas
vão passar o focus o cotonete xangai mas
tem cenas muito clique aqui
se for muito grande pode entrar no canal
o fundo vai conseguir apanhar agora é só
deixar os caras enquanto a champcar
divulgar esta peça aqui
e agora encaixar que agora também tem
deixado uma pequena distância aqui
embora o lugar ops já vão limpar o canal
este ano tenho aqui
é você ter esta claque que você entende
mais
agora é só porém se esta que tem ficado
bem alinhado com o outro do outro lado
para isso vou só pressionar cima da mesa
de força e vai ficar tudo bem alinhada
está a ver se cola por todo lado assim a
escola toda aqui pois vai atrapalhar na
hora de tirar
já ter aqui agora peguei nestas duas
pecinhas por com esta parte é só colocar
para fazer o mesmo por esse lado não
está usando o esquema muito simples que
só o tempo para dizer que não consegue
estar mais ou menos feito para baixo uma
vez que eu deixei para ficar o canal é
trunfo terá que utilizar só pode ser bem
mais vocês pois gosto então para
diminuir o atrito com as unhas muito bem
achei que o benefício de fato é que
desde menina em branco
é o contraste do branco agora se você
quiser usar o brinquedo muitas vezes vão
ter que reforçar esta conexão aqui com o
tempo você vai perdendo força
para isso um lugar aqui não tem escola e
por um dos lados aqui lateralmente
hoje aqui
agora vamos enrolar aqui está aqui deste
lado
até agora é com cuidado
quero passar por aqui passaram frio por
outro lado mas por baixo e não por cima
aqui porque aqui vai ser isso as faixas
pec por baixo
o galinho e continuar a testar agora
para finalizar somente vocês fazem
melhor em casa é porque outra escola e
só no final do anterior ter algo do
gênero disto você quiser pode fazer tem
cruz fazerem cruz pra gente tem que ser
devagar
aí eu vou explicar este fraco e não vou
fazer agora por um fio no ar
por isso que é muito grosso não vou ter
que tirar a empresa agora voltar aqui
vocês pra ficar bem intencionada da 1
hora
o banco sol eu fiz aqui já os cortes
para conseguir pôr um fio e não sei
porque é um caso complicado estar a
fazer a distância tem que fazer isso
mesmo perto dos meus olhos e pronto e
vou mostrar que o corte ocorre também
vai estar assinalado na imagem do
facebook
por dentro o gatilho até já vi que vou
mostrar tem que tocar no quênia a gente
chega aqui e agora vamos instalar aqui
agora vou ajustar o tamanho não se deve
fazer com a tesoura mas pronto pronto e
deixam tudo bem feita agora é difícil do
que a educativa esta parte aqui em cima
fica aqui dentro
e vejam que vai ser o meu fio ou seja
você largar em que vai mandar o filho
para cima e pará
agora uma coisa muito importante a
atenção pessoal vocês não vão por isso
assim ao mesmo nível do internamento
para baixo
agora é só corpo só aqui
vocês fazem mesmo por outro lado a
simples podem ver tudo bem fixa está
funcionando com diferentes posições
nela o corte só colocar a boca seca
podem ver agora está legal aquela grande
tem uma coisa para segurar as flechas
deixar suas casas mas não querem fazer
aqui um teste com nosso foco os seis
melhores no teste file sharing está
agora fica fixa pode parar em qualquer
ângulo
agora é só esperar o espetáculo está o
banho de sol
o deputado entende o que fazer agora é a
hora que eu peço o que eu acho que esse
projeto não é que é um favorito comer
sozinha e eu possa inscrição se não
forem inscritos no canal
pois é e mais uma coisa esse projeto
aqui um exemplo sempre meu projeto já
existente que basicamente esta besta de
ver um projeto aqui que o canal do sonic
dela
aos 35 que muito tem muita criatividade
e seringueiros ou qualquer coisa do
gênero
passei por lá e inscreva-se essas coisas
todas
aqui embaixo
não quero fazer vídeos do canal chocante
porque têm medo comecei a fazer e depois
não conseguir brancos tornando a posição
de acreditar naqueles onde acaba o exame
e vai cruzar o canal shop por isso vocês
quiserem poderá inscrever-se no canal
quando chegava em casa na instituição
obrigado steve então percebi
só perde ao e é só mandar assassino